so Joe Biden gave this speech last night
and if you have not seen any of the
video or the image of images of this
it's dystopian it's right out of Star
Wars Palpatine it's right out of Germany
1937. uh the the Optics of this thing
are absolutely horrible Biden again he's
just reading he doesn't know what he's
saying he can't regulate his emotions
all of that stuff well we got two clips
for you here and and just watch the
juxtaposition of what Biden does here
first
um we should be United
I believe America is at an inflection
point
one of those moments
that determine the shape of everything
that's to come after
and now America must choose
to move forward
or to move backwards
to build a future or obsess about the
past
to be a nation of Hope and unity and
optimism
or a nation of fear
Division and of Darkness
all right so he seems kind of angry
while he's telling us about unity and
all that good you know flowery stuff
then moments later he did this
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
so it's just so extraordinary what he
does and again it's not coming from him
so it's whoever the speechwriter is and
it's whoever the entire whoever's entire
in charge of the entire event we're
going to make him look evil we're going
to have the two soldiers behind him and
the red and it all just looked nazi-ish
and evil and it's by Design guys it
really is by Design no it's by Design I
get these people are incompetent but
they're not that incompetent they know
what they're doing so in this speech
first he's telling us about Hope and we
have to be less divisive and we have to
look forward not backward okay always
twirling twirling that's a Simpsons
reference for some of you
um then a minute later Donald Trump and
the Maga Republicans you know basically
saying that they're terrorists and it's
like uh you do know that's about 74
million people by your math on the
election right that's 74 million people
you're saying are in essence evil
um I don't think that's going to go that
well with those 74 million people and
these aren't Stakes this is by design
that is in a speech by Design to
purposely confuse and conflate everybody
and sort of make it sound like he wants
Unity while he's also throwing half the
country under the bus and this is not
the first time that he's done this this
I think was from about a week ago again
I'm getting caught up on all of this
stuff uh when uh he defended himself
after calling Maga Republicans
semi-fascist what did you mean by
semi-fashionism
[Music]
Senator Lindsey Graham said last night
there would be riots in the street if
former president Trump is prosecuted for
taking classified government documents
to Mar-A-Lago what is the White House
response to that so
um you can we have you know we have seen
Mega Republicans attack our democracy we
have seen Mega Republicans take away our
rights uh make threats of violence uh
including this weekend and that is what
the president was referring to uh when
you all asked me uh last week about the
semi-fascism comment
so if I can link this back to a little
bit of where we started with Sam Harris
stuff the point here is is that sort of
like Sam Harris they're now saying the
quiet part out loud they are okay uh
silencing people whether it's through
big Tech or whatever means they see fit
they are okay using the FBI to
investigate the former president or
whether they want to hire I'm told 87
000 new IRS agents to look into your
finances so that the government can take
more of your money armed agents by the
way they're saying all the quiet things
out loud they call you fascist they call
Donald Trump fascist the idea that he
would use the power of the state and and
corporations to crack down on people
while they're the ones who are doing it
they were the ones who used the levers
of the state to influence corporations
during covid to fire the very people who
earlier were deemed the essential
workers firing nurses who who wanted to
my body my choice everything everything
they say is a lie you and you when you
know it it frees you it absolutely frees
you